Salut, le mental vlog du jour sera beaucoup plus vlog que mental.
Parce que aujourd'hui... Y'a des camions qui passent.
Parce que aujourd'hui, pour la première fois, j'ai rendez vous au YouTube space.
Et je vais essayer de vous emmener avec moi, et je me dis si il y a bien un endroit où ça va pas choquer quelqu'un que j'ai une caméra, c'est au YouTube space.
Je vous emmène du côté de Saint-Lazarre.
*....musique/paysage...*
Le YouTube space se trouve au 8 rue de Londres, donc c'est pas très loin de Saint-Lazare.
Il faut que je remonte la rue d'Amsterdam et j'y suis.
Et donc la formation à laquelle je vais assister... Parce qu'ils font des formations aussi, c'est super.
C'est monter sois même, monter tout seul en fait.
J'espère que je vais apprendre des astuces, moi aussi, à mon tour ce coup-ci, pour monter plus efficacement.
Ou... ou je sais pas en fait... Bon ça devrait plus trop être loin je pense... Si je me suis pas planté...
*...musique-paysage...*
Je viens de finir la formation.
dans la YouTube space.
euh... Malheureusement j'ai pas pu filmer en fait. À partir d'un endroit quand on rentre chez Google on peut plus filmer. J'étais un peu dégoûté de ça je vous avoue.
Donc j'ai pas pu faire d'images. En plus le lieu il est tellement ouf.
Cherchez, il doit y avoir des reportages, des trucs comme ça.
Quand t'es là bas t'es un peu a la Silicone Valley.
T'as envie d'y habiter !!
t'as envie d'y travailler ! c'est IN-CRO-YA-BLE, c'est juste incroyable. Du coup je vais faire une autre formation qui s'appelle "unlock the space" qui va me permettre de pouvoir tourner aussi des vidéos, d'utiliser du matériel de là-bas et de tourner
et en faite je crois que je vais déménager au YouTube space. Je cherche la lumière en marchant parce que j'ai eu 2H de formations sur la lumière
et en faite ça c'est le truc un peu déprimant, tu sors de cette formation et tu te dis "ah ouai y'a encore du chemin pour avoir des vidéos de qualité"
Mais tant mieux, parce que ça veux dire que durant les semaines qui viennent, je vais, peut-être, réussir à sortir des vidéos de plus grande qualité.
Après la difficulté c'est de prendre en compte le fait qu'il faut en faire une par jour.
mais il va falloir surtout des petites économies avant de pouvoir faire les petits investissements.
Voila c'est la première vidéos où il n'y a pas vraiment de truc de mentalisme.
Mais je trouvais ça cool de vous emmener, un petit peu dans mon périple de la journée, de ma découverte de YouTube en fait.
Où je suis passé de mon rapport à YouTube qui se fait à l'ordi sur le terrain, en réel.
Je repars.
Donc j'ai juste un truc à vous dire : pensez à vous abonnez à la chaîne évidement parce que c'est grâce a vous que je suis motivé aussi à faire tout ça
et à faire toutes ces formations,
pour vous faire des vidéos de meilleure qualité.
...outro...
À demain 11h, ciao !